[Music]
hey it's lindsey and welcome to my
closet i'm a buzzfeed producer and
professional fan girl and i'm what you'd
call someone that came from the one
direction fan to k-pop fan pipeline so
what's going to go down today is going
to come into my closet and style me for
a week whatever they put me in i have to
wear it they could put me in like a
dinosaur costume and i'd be happy
honestly i'd wear anything espa's look
is very cool
avatar-esque futuristic but also there's
so much color there's so many textures i
don't know if i have very avatar-ish
stuff my stuff looks like it came out of
like lizzie mcguire's closet i just want
the esp effect i just wanted them to rub
off on me you know all right
bring them in i'm shaking can you see my
hands
shake city over here
hi this is karina hi this is gisele
hi this is winter
hi this is ming ning i love the tiny
claps
because your style is so amazing you're
going to be styling me for a whole week
wow
so excited how are you feeling about
that since we're always the ones getting
styled we're super excited to be styling
someone else it's true yeah describe it
your own style in three words simple
edgy minimal vintage y2k unique simple
natural
comfortable black edgy and fashion where
does your style inspo come from iran
oh that's fine i'm gonna start doing
that when i don't know what to wear i'll
just put my phone
so you each get to choose a day of the
week i will have to wear whatever you
choose for me for that day of the week
and you also get to decide what i gotta
do that day so really yeah do you like
just pajamas and like a day at home
do you have any questions for me what's
your favorite color i like pink and
green a lot what is your hobby i have a
skateboard i like skateboarding a girl i
like sleeping
what's your favorite type of music i
love k-pop and i love harry styles
you're like meant to be
here
which day of the week would you like to
claim friday oh because in korea
it's freaking
fire you can
have fun sunday i go to the farmers
market on sundays
saturday wednesday why do you like wins
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
i want to buy this
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning happy sunday so excited for
today's look oh i'm nervous because it's
a little more skin showing than i
normally work for the farmer's market so
we'll see we'll see what it looks like
on here's the thing i feel like winter
and i
could be best friends
she just doesn't know it yet
i don't know if you're ready for this
oh
this is like pop star goes to the
farmer's market 101. i actually love
this a lot this hat i'm obsessed with
these are some of my favorite sunglasses
and i am a sucker for denim on denim the
hairy kicks are you kidding me it's like
she met me for like five minutes and
then totally made an elevated lindsay
outfit harry's house more like winter's
house
off to the farmer's market we go
we're just going to get vegetables
i felt so cute today
i really appreciated the sun hat and
crop top because it was a hot day i
picked up some veggies some cute flowers
and said hi to some puppies overall i
felt really confident in this outfit
thanks winter
okay controversial question low rise or
high rise juice oh
low rise higher
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
this is wednesday outfit so lindsay had
to ride skateboard danny bear
anna
[Music]
[Music]
happy wednesday and happy skateboarding
and be careful
perfect
you're so wonderful amazing
beautiful
hello happy wednesday karina chose the
most lindsay look these overalls i wear
all the time she said to do lots of
coral blush which i'm obsessed with and
just a glossy pink lip she how does she
know me so well i don't know gonna go to
the beach and have a little beachgate
day i'm very excited you guys i feel
adorable in this i also feel so much
like me but a little bit elevated i
never wear bracelets for some reason
this is my favorite part of the look
karina also said to care any necklace
that i think would look good with it
pigtails obsessed these sunglasses
classic
let's go to the beach baby i need to put
some deodorant on i'm sweating
ugh going to the beach on a wednesday
instantly made my week better i felt so
comfy and cute in this outfit i skated
and skated and skated some more
honorable mention to this perfect golden
retriever and then i laid out on the
beach karina thank you so much for
giving me this effortlessly cool look
is there a style you want to try for a
future comeback that you have not done
yet
i want to try like just full on simple
watery rides
you play sports oh no
hi i'm
friday i'm gonna give you a hot and cute
outfit to hang out with your friends
let's go check out
wonder world
like a chihuahua
me
[Laughter]
sorry you can
hold this this coke
hannah montana friday
hot girl
hang out with your friends with this
office and get some drinks have a good
friday
cheers to ning-ning and this crazy
outfit i'm going out to karaoke with my
girlfriends i told them in the group
chat the theme is go go girl meets
bachelorette party something i love
about ning ning is the confidence she
radiates and not being afraid to take a
risk
it's giving go go it's giving lola from
here in montana it's getting confused
but hot you know what if ning ning says
this is a purse this is a purse oh my
hair's caught in it i was scared but
seeing it all together oh
look baby
[Music]
bringing a disco ball to karaoke is loki
genius it was so surreal singing to espa
at karaoke in an outfit ning ning picked
for me we were having a blast dancing
laughing singing
my wig fell off i think it was a
metaphor for a successful girls night
out
what is your advice to fans who might be
struggling with their self-confidence i
think it's best to
find what suits you you can have an icon
or you can have someone like a role
model or an inspiration but to really
know yourself and what fits you and what
looks good on you is like the best thing
hello kitty
[Music]
[Music]
can i give you two outfits
sure okay okay here's an option option
assist
there's two outfits
so far one is for like a really casual
saturday maybe if you're hungover from
ding ning's purgum yeah then one is if
maybe ningling's friday wasn't enough
fun for you
for another night out
you'll need a
bag
okay i'm done the first outfit it's all
black outfit obviously with the combat
boots the hello kitty is kind of cute
and just comfy shorts these small little
poopies for this look straight hair and
with makeup barely any for this outfit
is if you want to have a little more fun
on saturday
and
and for pants i didn't know which would
look good because lindsay has really
long legs whatever fits your you know
look more and to top it off with this
hat hair for this look straight hair and
for makeup a little smoky and some
nice eyelashes have a good saturday
night means night messed me up real good
she knew what ningling had in store for
me and knew that i needed to be
comfortable you know some might say
giselle's look is the chillest out of
the bunch but for me it's actually gonna
be a wild card because i don't wear
black wait i love this outfit i feel
like giselle as soon as we stopped
rolling she was like wait i didn't see
these glasses and then she handed them
to me it's grungy comfortable i kind of
feel like an idol that just showed up to
the airport and all the paparazzi are
like lindsay lindsay and i'm like oh
time to go get coffee
this outfit was making me spiral because
it is so unlike anything i'd normally
wear but i also felt so cool in it and
then went home to have a relaxing
saturday
so i thought it's like 10 o'clock at
night my friend texted me was like do
you want to go to the bar with me and my
friends down the street and i was like
normally i'd say no but i have an outfit
for that
i'm actually excited for this look
because i am feeling a little moody
tonight
so
let's see this on okay i'm rushing but
wow wow this is a look i have these
little star earrings to go with this top
so freaking cute i feel like a starry
dream girl i'll see you guys at the bar
i still can't believe i'm going out it
is past my bedtime
i actually got so many compliments on
this look at the bar i felt like a
shining star and i couldn't have asked
for a better outfit to close out one of
the coolest fashion weeks of my life i
just want to say thank you to all the
girls for putting so much thought and
effort into these looks
thanks so much for being here in my
closet and styling me
thank you so much for having us it's
been so much fun and please be sure to
check out our new album
girls thank you
[Music]
foreign